[Music]
for 24 years i was an investigator for
the irs and the fbi
i started off working bank robbery cases
i ended up in chicago and worked
political corruption cases
and after i retired i
started investigating lost apple
varieties
[Music]
in the late 1800s apples were extremely
important to early settlers in
washington
they grew a variety of apples
most of those people decided that
farming was too hard but all over
eastern washington those old orchards
survive to this day
sometimes i'll just drive country roads
and i'll look out and i can recognize an
apple tree from you know a couple
hundred yards away
i wonder what's planted there it's very
possible it could be one of these lost
varieties of apple just waiting to be
found
i draw on my experience as an
investigator mainly through the use of
records
i'm searching for clues of
of where these lost varieties grew i
look at plat maps i look through museum
records and things like that
then i go out just like in law
enforcement i'm looking for physical
evidence
and i've got to take a look at those
apples
i make a map and record the gps
coordinates i bag them up and i mail
them off to apple identification experts
i'm
collecting these apples
from the only known
dickinson apple tree in the united
states
these apples are absolutely delicious
off the tree there's only about
10 of us now that have ever tasted the
dickinson in the last 100 years
i began searching for lost apple
varieties probably about eight nine
years ago something like that
[Music]
people often ask me why do you look for
these apples and i tell them that i have
been concerned that if i don't look for
them no one else will
and these varieties could be lost
forever
so far i found
three lost varieties of apples those
varieties include the nero and then the
arkansas beauty and the dickinson
so we're down to about 20 varieties that
we're looking for right now and just a
matter of time hopefully to find those
[Music]
you